the governor of Florida Ron DeSantis is
expected to formally announce he will
run for the U.S presidency today
call it Faith because in the face of
Darkness you can see that brighter
future
ahead of the much anticipated
announcement his wife Casey released
this video on Twitter mark Stone has
more
well as an announcement of a
presidential run goes it is hardly
conventional Florida's governor Ronda
Santos will take to Twitter for a live
conversation tonight with Twitter owner
Elon Musk but then Rhonda Santos is no
conventional politician he is deeply
skeptical of the media he's vehemently
anti-woke a self-styled woke Warrior who
has banned school books which he deems
to be inappropriate he's bound abortion
after six weeks he's picked a bitter
legal battle with the state's largest
employer Disney as well to be clear
Donald Trump Remains the favorite
Republican party nominee the question is
could DeSantis be his disrupter de
Santas is a man who some say is Trump
without the chaos a man who has parroted
so many trumpian policies could he
deliver those in a way Trump never
really managed to that makes him for
some a very exciting candidate for
others a pretty frightening one remember
too that President Biden's approval
rating is terrible Democrats are really
concerned and all over the country we
speak to people who have unease about
Biden not least because of his age the
election not is not until November next
year but already it is proving to be
fascinating all eyes over the next few
days here in Miami as DeSantis tries to
get that all-important money for a
presidential run money that will come
from donors